didn't so greetings
[Music]
oh [__] it's that time you dirty [__]
uncle Joey time that said it's over
[Music]
if you're under 18 hang up now
because I think there's a [__]
nightmare for you understand this is
gonna be a nightmare for you tonight I
know people that have already called
ambulances they have them on call
it's gonna be an ugly night here in the
church
[Music]
you
and see the light oh yeah
are you [__] nuts or what Memorial
Day weekend [__] is coming uncle
Joey he runned 18th hang up now my ears
are itching and [__] q-tip time the
debt I packed the wax in there like
[__] gunpowder George Washington stop
a [__] chunk of wax is gonna come out
pretty soon but who gives a [__] about a
wax we're talking about Monday night
[__] pure entertainment from the
heart whatever these plans you had
homework whatever the [__] you gonna do
stop right now we're going deep tonight
you understand me
we got the stars two different colors we
got a [__] cantaloupe soaked taffy
and guess what we got lurking Raoul oh
[__]
we got [__] a jar with handwriting on
it that's always a bad sign and right
here we got a little [__] black them
from perennial we're prepared you
understand me the question is are you
prepared if you're on day teams hang up
now what's not [__] quickly no drama
sales oh [__]
taking it to the out of [__]
limits if you're in you're in 200 down
couples we got [__] Sabbath bloody
Sabbath on killing yourself to live
you're going to Starbucks you talking to
you [__] [__] French and in reality
you're killing yourself to [__] live
get this damn it whether black is white
or blue is brown colors in my life are
all different somehow you know what
[Music]
mmm-hmm if I told you once I told you
many times and young 18 hang up now in
this damn you're gonna pick up bad
habits watchin it [__] Michelle the
church coming at you in about 20 minutes
wanna listen to one of my longtime
favorite albums Sabbath bloody Sabbath
just brought me back when I was a
[__] young man I was having dark
thoughts but this album let me know I
was alright and I had to [__] prove
my own and get on the [__] get on the
horse and kick that [__] mule
understand it
kick the mule is not an expression it's
a state of mind you take the mule every
day
[__] the Humane Society what they don't
see they don't know you understand me
oh [__] one down one to go
who said [__] bong get up debt uncle
Joey uncle Joey here we go
[Music]
that's a little [__] bondage sorry
about that I was just cleaning out the
box please sitting there patiently Joey
what am i [__] chopped liver I'm ready
to go here Trump put a note in the wall
you know what that book that note said
suck my dick and call me shorty I was
born in 1940 I'm with the Jews
[__] I've been telling you for
years if you ain't with the Jews you
ain't got dick you understand me you
gotta have a Jew friend and Armenian
friend and then you're all complete yeah
running on Armenian you're missing out
it's like having a group on [__]
coupon book in your pocket these
[__] don't pay for not the full
price you understand me and everything
is on the arm don't worry about it we'll
send you an IOU
yeah they don't give a [__] jack I don't
know who [__] Armenians hate more the
Turks over they don't [__] around they
hate it believe you're ready for the
bonding of death yeah let's do this [__]
it's Monday night [__] get your [__]
together there's only one life and
you're living it [__] oh [__]
[Music]
kill that mule kill that meal there you
go there you go that's the meal with
debt you say I'm saying we [__]
around tonight you got doubts there you
go there you go right there there's what
I'm talking about I got this weed that
delays in your lung it's like time
release is like is like a [__] cold
medicine yeah I'm saying look at him
he's all red in the face his eyeballs
about to pop up that's what we're
dealing with you be inner yard you're
coming to the Voodoo Lounge
you gonna mess up stories where's
[__] talking laughs where's my
[__] goombazz I
[Music]
tremendous and the best part of this is
hanging out with you [__]
that's what it's all about
it's Monday night uncle Joey's in your
[__] living room you understand me
with his loyal [__] goombah Lisa at
the Prime Minister of Israel still on
the hunt for [__] Nazis you
understand me they've not given up we're
gonna look [__] Nazis wherever the
[__] they are anyway forget about Nazis
right now we're smoking reefer having a
good time
why put sorrow into this [__] evening
you understand me we got enough [__]
sorrows in our life as it is anyway who
said bong hit who said chocolate oh yeah
OOP dope dude my [__] I gotta clean
this up
and they ain't hitting probably well you
ready for a buck this is the prime
minister of [__] Israel's refill in
the Stan Lee from the very start
[Music]
I don't think you're so smart what tubes
but [__] tubes
oops death understand me I got more
tubes in the two people but those
chocolate containers yeah oh I got that
I bring them back every cycle I got my
own tube recycling stop stalling
[__] you're stalling I'm not
stalling they go this is this is the
week that may punches pilot hang himself
let's do this let's do this let's do
this let's do this let's do this is the
one
[Music]
are you kidding me or what just when you
thought it was safe
who the [__] are you dealing with wasn't
Pontius Pilate it was Judas
look at these eyeballs that's a [__]
eyeball right they understand me I gotta
put [__] toothpicks on my boss if not
they call me Joey Chinese you know I'm
saying it was the last time you got
caught
Joey Chinese never but I'm certainly fan
that I thought that oh [__] will rocket
now [__] old school
[Music]
there you go just when you thought it
was safe you got smoke in your [__]
eyeballs you understand me they don't
even teach you how to evade this [__] at
the academy anyway
guess what time it is well all the time
oh [__] bring it in the [__] new year
getting rid of all the airspeed source
models in the studio it's over you
understand me and let me tell you how I
eat these let me be level with you here
this did the same [__] oh [__]
just when you thought it was [__]
safety you want another boy we're about
to eat the trumpet of death here
different mother represented drugs as
[__] Lisa alley uses the flying Jew
direct from Israel when Trump put that
note the [__] [__] you're
gonna have somebody smiling I got back
in the seventh grade another GD implant
ain't no [__] tip-top Magoo genius
but I got high [__] and that's
the most important thing we got bums
we got weed we got edibles we got water
we got a panicking for you whatever you
want we got him we got liquid acid we
got a liquid asset we got regular acid
we got edibles we got sugar cubes for
the acid look we got sugar cubes for the
[__] ass
[Music]
what's that time you told me you spoke
to all but who says we're too old to
like MDMA pure is [__] from the
pharmacist now for that you'll be
rubbing these [__] titties get hold
you chop up the tree usually drop in
like cuz I said I said that one [__]
killings up like the bug and you do
wanna live life as Chris Cornell and
these brothers got diabetes with [__]
yeah
they don't take care that diabetes that
diabetes the silent [__] killer dog I
don't [__] with sugar after [__] late
night all these edibles are 15 calories
that's the reason why they got like yeah
man because I'll tell you were sure and
sure we'd always helps as a matter of
fact I went to Jersey and I brought my
brothers in CBD uh he's a hard-headed
[__] like me this dude called me
yesterday and said dawg that's just the
real deal
I go how do you know he goes well my dog
is dying of liver cancer
and figure what the [__] got learn to
lose I spot a given room three sprays a
night a month later his numbers turned
around he's still gonna die but I bought
him an extra six [__] months to see
big deal
this is no [__] yeah do I believe in see
I didn't [__] believe any I took
these [__] dude let me tell you
something I know one thing about white
people when they get emotional by [__]
when they start picking up their kids
and moving to Colorado
that's when you know there's a secret in
there's a movie that's when you know
it's a secret in that dog I hope you
enjoy the chocolate stop Dennis [__]
bong hits the hole [__] deal tonight
old school one of the [__] one of the
founders one of the originals be proud
of the Bronx New York who the [__] you
think you're dealing with him to stab me
this guy was dead when it all was going
down in the early stages and they're
still on [__] tour you know people
think I'm crazy that glass old-school
disco on him you know I'm still four I
still listen to a lesion [__] DJ from
New York that went to prison it was a
[Music]
wait for that [__] to show up to
shock these [__] nobody nobody
knows about Blacula the original Dracula
he was half-dragon a half pimp whoever
wrote that scripture to won an Academy
Award oh that gave him dick you
understand me
yeah let me tell you it's all my black
yellow right Blacula I met that dude
[Music]
black you know right Dracula rain
Blacula screen right that's right
I want to say his name was William
something Liam something yes William it
was an actor from the 15th right all
that buzzing so busted
so back in the days we're doing the
original house party me in place
and we did anteriors over the culvert
cover since studios and on the same
cover City Studios our stage was near
the stage they used to do pee-wee's
Playhouse
but Saturday morning show okay pee-wee
Herman right so pee-wee Herman they
should be on the same table vcp with him
in there but a lot of people forget who
else was on that show Blacula
you do they play black killer was on
that show I forgot what his character
was but who else was on that show was
Laurence Fishburne yes he was cowboy
Curtis this is when he was still Larry
Fishburne but you know but Blackie
learns and yo and know we know you know
we Lou Lawrence from back in the days he
was the home you were like oh you know
me and Tripp and he got home cowboy gear
like he ain't he I turned her yet he
none of the hailer then you let him it's
like Morgan Freeman maybe you remember
Morgan Freeman for a mohawk electric
company okay we know Morgan Freeman
Oscar Morgan you know same we know back
in the days same thing like Laurence
Fishburne right but man we was more
deeply like [__] [__] Blacula
and you played some kind of carries or
whatever on the show without me you look
it up right Lee come on Lee we'll do it
during the show during the show we'll do
it this is interesting [__] right here
Jackie you see you're learning about
Blacula when the [__] have you ever
learned about blackulas yeah I'm saying
this is why you have to watch the church
ever Bakula that's right we're talking
about Blacula fix the original black you
have [__] Dracula you understand me
and get your [__] together if anybody
should want to Cara Mia warm oh it was
black youlet but a whatever gets to
godfather but what if there was a Cuban
human dragon who they call
I don't know - pikapika put on ice the
Mexicans [__] Cubans would be
subluxation
we wish that chocolate threw away
[__] I know you threw it away you
still have ten stars through regular
we're going deep tonight we are going
deep plan to the murky waters I'm
telling you [__] get your bomb
call your boss tell him you ain't gonna
work tomorrow
please puking on water looking oh he
made it
but he's trying to tell you guys my man
died he was eating him he was faking
kick cats
he said I'm saying we busted him
red-handed his [__]
Thomas he was faking the funk he was
saying he was he knows he took the thing
I they put kid cats in there you can't
tell the difference in you put take cats
in there he doesn't think I know but I
[__] know I'm watching these populum
and giggling and talking to his wife
takes him an hour he's a little [__]
piece of chocolate I would never you did
it you like Bernie Madoff oh my god yo
they got their movies I saw it I saw it
sadly I saw the lights the one where I'm
doing it we have Robert De Niro get it
something good yeah it was good Richard
Dreyfuss right did you see that one no
but he looked like he didn't even look
like he could I saw that the little clip
of it I was flipping and I watched like
a singer too quick Robert De Niro got
him you know probably never got a freak
right
right you did like I'll tell you [__]
yeah we shake the tower we're Paul
sorvino's and I got ya no no TV thing
and I got and I got cake it's [__]
crazy to watch yeah you to.com slash c /
Church ten minutes youtube.com slash c /
church / Joey D is where the [__] you
want to do keep smoking that reefer will
be back in your living room in 10
minutes with the Church of what's
happening now stay black